let's talk to jersey's external
relations minister
ian gorst good to see you this morning
that what's the latest
situation as you understand it
well so far we're pleased that the
protest or demonstration has been
uh peaceful the main vessel that brings
in supplies has arrived in jersey
it is of course slightly delayed uh
leaving
but the protest has been uh peaceful
my uh environment ministerial colleagues
uh together with officials will be going
out to listen to the fishermen later
this morning
on the hopes of achieving what i mean by
actually getting out there and talking
to them do you think you can actually
reach some sort of agreement
well the answer to the difficulties that
we
currently face is without doubt talking
and diplomacy but equally we've had
disproportionate threats emanating from
paris as you've
mentioned and the potential blockade of
our main harbour
and those threats we take seriously to
protect uh jersey's interests
in terms of of the misunderstanding here
what has gone wrong i mean has that
had has jersey done so could you could
you have been clearer
in what you needed these people to
provide in terms of paperwork and
records that would have made this whole
process easier
well of course the um new trade post
brexit deal is clear that evidence had
to be provided of the nature and extent
of
historic fishing rights we want to give
french fishermen who can prove they have
fished in our waters historically
the rights that they had previously but
evidence has to be provided
now there is a little bit of a
bureaucratic process because that
evidence has to go from normandy to
paris paris to the eu
eu to london and then down to jersey and
it's become
apparent uh since we issued the first
licenses on friday
that not all of that evidence has been
presented
and therefore talking and helping
fishermen to be
able to provide that evidence means
we'll be able to adjust their licenses
and that is the way through uh the
problems that we're currently
experiencing
so you you're confident are you that
that can be done what in a matter of
days
well these things have got to be agreed
by the
uh eu it's really important
that we talk that we find solutions
and that we have the eu approval and we
answer any questions that might
emanate from the eu let's not forget our
fishermen of course
have post uh the 1st of january
found it difficult and bureaucratic to
land their fish
into france and so reaching agreement
alleviating some of those uh issues and
concerns
and then providing the data to help us
update the licenses
that is the answer uh to the problems
that are being experienced
what what do you make of the fact that
the french maritime vessel athos has
has been dispatched to your waters
well uh the latest intelligence is that
it's not been dispatched to
our waters of course it would need to
seek permission
to come into jersey and british waters
uh we've not been informed that they've
sought permission either from us
or from the uk uh ministry of defense
but we are very close to france we're
only uh 14 miles away
uh so they can remain in french waters
and still be
uh close to us yeah well is it do you
perceive that as a threat is it
is it a threatening move why have they
done it
well french vessels uh and military
assets
uh can sail where they wish in french
waters that's uh
part of the uh autonomy and sovereignty
of any nation or any island
so you so you don't i mean obviously you
know when that news came through
it does seem like it is at the very
least
a response to to the royal navy sending
two ships you
you're determined not to see it in that
way are you
well we were very grateful that the
prime minister last night
uh said he gave us his full support and
offered the assets to be deployed down
into jersey waters
as a precautionary measure to ensure
that the
demonstration was a demonstration and
not a blockade
and that it went uh peacefully and we
welcome a peaceful
demonstration we understand that
tensions are running high
and so far uh that precautionary measure
uh has has worked so what time is is
your colleague heading out
to talk to the fishermen
uh later this morning nothing more
specific than that at this stage
well i don't have those details in front
of me okay
senator good to talk to you thank you